hi there Steve Kaufman here today I want
to talk about language learning goals
and frustrations but before I get into
the subject I want to thank everyone
that sent me those nice birthday
greetings it's very nice to hear from
all of you it's nice to feel that
somehow I'm connected to a great
community of people who share a common
interest with me which is language
learning I haven't been able to reply to
all of you but I do appreciate it very
much it's also encouraging to find out
that quite a few people actually listen
through to the middle of my video where
I mentioned the fact that it was my
birthday for those of you who are
curious I was I am now 68 no I have
lunch earlier this week with a college
professor who's head of a a language
department in a university and he told
me that a majority of students who
enroll in Asian languages quit after the
first year which I was quite surprised
to hear but then I did some research on
the internet and in fact I wrote a blog
post about this at my blog you'll find
the link to my blog in the description
of this video and discovered that you
know the attrition rate the dropout rate
on all kinds of language programs is
very very high this is true if it's
whether it's online learning whether
it's they had an example in Australia
where 94% of kids taking Mandarin
Chinese in the school system didn't
complete the program and in the end it
ended up being Mandarin speakers
teaching Mandarin speakers Mandarin
because in effect the only kids that
stayed in the program were Chinese
immigrants who already spoke Mandarin I
guess they needed an easy credit we have
the same situation here so but getting
back to this professor in our discussion
he I said but why did they quit and he
said well they discover how hard it is
and it's a lot of work so they don't
want to do it and
during our conversation we also
expressed some dissatisfaction with the
recent trends in language acquisition
that's that are moving away from grammar
and it's more as he put a touchy-feely
communication and stuff like that well
you know I there are lots of fads in
language instruction I'm not a great fan
of the role-playing they have a thing in
Canada called the task-based language
learning where they sort of create these
false scenarios where you pretend you
are you know the checkout person in a
store or whatever it might be and people
play roles I don't believe in that as
you know I believe in a lot of listening
and reading as much as possible to
subjects of interest this becomes easier
as you progress in the language and at
some point you started speaking and
hopefully you speak in situations that
are meaningful to you and not artificial
situations that to me is an ideal
scenario but what was interesting to me
was this professor with this enormous
dropout rate was mostly upset about the
fact that students weren't prepared to
put in the hard work that language
instruction was methodology or pedagogy
was moving away from the center
traditional emphasis on grammar and I
thought myself you know I wonder whether
at that University trying to figure out
how to reduce the attrition rate the
dropout rate whether that in fact would
not be a worthwhile subject of inquiry
and so then I thought to myself you know
and I should add that one of the
comments I think on Facebook where my
blog article about this dropout rate
appeared was a student who said that he
was studying Russian and the teacher
came in on day one and said class you're
gonna be doing a lot of writing a lot of
memorizing and that's the only way
you're gonna learn and he found this
message quite discouraging and so I
thought to myself Oh
mm-hmm how do we encourage people to
stay with the program but beyond that
what is the goal what is the goal of
someone taking
you know an Asian language Russian
Spanish whatever it might be in a
university a school it's over what are
they trying to achieve the assumption
with this sort of role-playing is that
they want to be a you know checkout girl
in a supermarket or they want to develop
some very you know specific skills for
specific functions and I've always felt
that that was not really that useful
because even if you have a script for a
specific function you can't control
what's gonna come at you and so that
actually you need a much larger
knowledge base in order to be able to
cope with these apparently simple tasks
so what are they what are the possible
goals in a university program well I
mean universities offer programs and
things like music appreciation Gender
Studies you know art the history of art
I mean these programs are not
necessarily aimed exclusively at the
person who's going to become a curator
at a at an art museum or you know music
music critic for a newspaper it's just
general education now I have often been
critical of the way we fund our
universities because a lot of this
general education if the person is
genuinely interested that person can
acquire much of that invention education
on their own as is of course the case
also with language instruction but get
me back the idea of goals if the goal is
say in a Russian program is to to make
the person stay with it enjoy it get a
sense of the language get a sense of the
culture be able to access some of the
works of the culture I think all of
those things would be very meaningful to
try and enforce the absolute correct
production of all the cases and the
aspects of verbs in Russia upon someone
who has had essentially no I mean going
into had no exposure to Russia seems to
me
guaranteed to discourage
majority of students a small minority
who are very motivated will pursue it
and will also go out and get you know
the other input that they that they need
but it just struck me that the goal of
the university should be how do we
retain these people how do we make it
interesting for them how do we provide
them with something that they can take
away from this year that's gonna be or
eventually hopefully for year for years
that's going to be beneficial to them
those that you know after two or three
years really want to hone their Russian
skills at that time it's not too late to
go in there and for those that really
want to be you know translators or
interpreter it's fine do something for
them but the emphasis on predict correct
production of the language and and
forcing on them a lot of rote
memorization and writing exercises and
so forth when the majority of them are
not going to be using Russian in any
case and with the result that the
majority quit you know that strikes me
as not a very good approach furthermore
you know a university program like here
in Canada students pay around three to
five thousand dollars depending on which
program which province they're in and
whereas the the cost of the university
education is probably around thirty
thousand dollars I mean the universities
charged foreign students twenty six
thousand dollars and claim that they
cover their costs I don't believe them
so I'm assuming that it's at least
twenty-six thousand dollars it anyway
it's not worth quibbling typically
students have five courses in a year
so therefore if one of them is a
language course that course costs
someone the taxpayer or someone four or
five thousand dollars and if the
majority of students quit then for the
majority of students that four or five
thousand dollars is simply thrown away
now since the taxpayer picks up 80
percent of the bill
I don't think students should be allowed
to take these language courses unless
they have demonstrated that they have
the willpower the commitment the
interest to actually stay with it and
the best way to do that is to
give them some kind of self learning
system likely not just link it could be
anything rosetta stone doesn't matter I
see I'll demonstrate first that you are
interested enough in this language that
you are gonna stick with it and once
you've demonstrated that then you are to
apply for the language program now of
course if the students are paying their
own shot then that's fine they can pay
for but if the taxpayers paying for it
there should be some requirement and one
of the we once dealt with a company in
France a large company that offered
language training to their employees but
only to those that had for six months
stayed with some kind of a distance or
online or self learning program to
demonstrate their interest and I think
this only makes sense but again it comes
back to the goals what are we trying to
achieve and I think you know in my own
case I mean Russian check the languages
that I've been learning Korean dabbling
in Korea and stuff like that I'm doing
it for my own enjoyment to access the
the culture to broaden my horizons my
perspectives events to go to the country
and communicate I don't have to nail
down every case Andy in order to derive
significant benefit and maybe students
should be asked what is your goal
why are you studying these languages
because you're interested in the culture
in which case we don't need to be so
heavy-handed on enforcing you know
absolutely correct production of the
language especially if it turns out that
that discourages learners so you know I
think wherever languages are taught
given the high dropout rate frustration
rate attrition rate the number one
consideration should be how do we keep
people motivated how do we keep people
with the program because if people put
in the time and if they are motivated
they will learn they will learn that may
not become perfect but under the
existing system most of drop up so it
seems to me
time for another reproach dare I suggest
link thank you for listening bye for now